un nuevo revés para los intentos por
frenar la pandemia este martes la fed y
el cdc de estados unidos recomendaron
suspender el uso de las dosis
desarrolladas por el laboratorio janssen
filial de la multinacional johnson and
johnson tras registrar casos de
coagulación sanguínea
hoy la fda y el cdc emitimos una
declaración sobre la vacuna del cuvi 19
de johnson and johnson recomendamos una
pausa en el uso de esta vacuna por
precaución de los 6,8 millones de
personas que han recibido las dosis de
janssen en eeuu fueron 6 mujeres menores
de 50 años las que registraron coágulos
graves y extraños una de ellas han
muerto y otra está en estado grave no
obstante la fed ha remarcado que la
gente no debe tener miedo ya que los
beneficios de la vacuna son mucho
mayores a los riesgos desde la casa
blanca han asegurado que este percance
no afectará la vacunación nacional ni al
objetivo de joe biden de aplicar 200
millones de dosis en sus primeros 100
días
por precaución la fda y el cdc han
recomendado una pausa en la vacuna de
johnson and johnson tenemos suministros
más que suficientes de facer y modernas
para continuar con el ritmo actual de
vacunación de 3 millones de inyecciones
diarias tras la noticia la compañía ha
decidido retrasar la distribución de
dosis en europa allí la emea empezó a
investigar las el viernes bajo sospechas
de coagulación aunque ha remarcado que
no hay ninguna relación clara entre la
vacuna y los casos de trombos la vacuna
de janssen es de las pocas que se
aplican una sola dosis por lo que es
vista como un arma para frenar la
pandemia sobre todo en los países con
menos recursos para neutralizar el
hobbit 19 usa un virus conocido como
adenovirus y tiene una eficacia del 66
9% su suspensión temporal podría afectar
al ritmo de vacunación mundial